on va continuer à parler de cette
journée de mobilisation avec emilie
marsh conseillère régionale la france
insoumise auvergne rhône-alpes mais les
marches bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors la faire
michel est claire a montré l'importance
justement de la vidéo dans ce genre de
situation c'est l'article 24 de cette
proposition de loi prévoit
l'interdiction de filmer les policiers
c'est important de manifester
aujourd'hui
oui c'est c'est important est de toute
façon on le voit au vu du nombre de
d'organisation qui appellent à
manifester nous avons beaucoup de rng
nous avons les organisations politiques
de gauche les syndicalistes
ça commence à faire quand même pas mal
et beaucoup de monde les syndicats de
deux journalistes aussi parce que
évidemment
oui il faut enfin on voit bien avec le
scandale et la honte que c'est sur le
tabassage de michel est clair que s'il
n'y avait pas eu ces images il aurait
pas pu prouver on n'aurait pas pu
prouver les violences policières qui
sont malheureusement de plus en plus
fréquentes parce que non ce n'est pas un
acte isolé
il ya de plus en plus de répression
policière que ça soit dans les manifs ou
même au quotidien
est ce que l'art est ce que l'état de
droit est aujourd'hui en danger en
france très clairement oui elle et puis
toute façon il ya aussi l'onu qui le dit
il ya le défenseur de droits iliad mr
internationale qui qui dit que que ça
porte attentes mais sa portée en tête
aussi à la liberté de la presse et aux
journalistes qui ne peuvent plus qu'ils
ne pourront plus filmée au qui pourront
se faire prendre leur matériel et aussi
ces derniers temps nous avons de plus en
plus de cas de journalistes qui ont
porté plainte parce qu'on a cassé leurs
appareils photos parce qu'on a pris
leurs caméras parce qu'on les a empêchés
de filmer et outre le tabassage honteux
de michel est clair nous avons eu aussi
le même jour ce qui s'est passé place de
la république où on a menacé des
journalistes et des élus de la
république empêchant de pouvoir aider et
de ne pas voir les violences policières
face à la police qui voulait enlever un
camp de migrants les violences justement
qu'on a pu voir lundi dernier pendant la
manif et pendant le
la dispersion du camp de migrants mais
également cette vidéo 2
de michel leclerc ont provoqué une
cascade de réactions politiques on a vu
manimal macron qui est sorti de son
silence hier soir des images qui nous
font honte est ce que aujourd'hui voilà
ces affaires de violence policière met à
mal la gouvernance d'eads emmanuel
macron ba et met à mal oui mais ces
violences policières en fait elles sont
elles sont quasi quotidiennes
le mouvement des gilet jaune il ya eu
combien des borniers combien de
personnes qui ont perdu un homme qui
sont mortes ou coucou qui ont été
blessées ou tabasser en règle là après
image elle est particulièrement violente
parce que cette personne n'avait rien
fait s'est fait tabasser par par des
policiers et on voit clairement les
images et une dizaine de policiers qui
ne font rien et donc en fait oui ça met
en mal oui alors emmanuel macron il en
est désolé moi j'attends des actes en
fait un moment donné c'est juste pas
possible et la réaction de darmanin
voilà ils en font un peu plus il faut
aussi que les gipn fasse clairement son
travail et que ça ne soit pas classée
sans suite et qui est une sanction en
des policiers parce que non ce n'est pas
possible
la police est là pour sécuriser et pas
pour tabasser des gens il ne faut plus
qu'on ait peur de la police peur quand
on vend manifestation peur peur dans les
quartiers populaires voilà il faut
remettre de la confiance entre le peuple
et la police sinon oui on n'est plus en
état de droit justement l'igpn qui s'est
saisi de la faire mais il faut savoir
que la police des polices ce sont quand
même des policiers qui vont être chargés
de juger et des policiers est ce que
finalement voilà l'igpn devrait-il être
indépendant ne pas dépendre du ministère
de l'intérieur à sa très clairement oui
il faut qu'il soit il faut qu'il soit
indépendant et qu'il faut mettre un peu
plus d'indépendance et aussi
du respect mais l'igpn il faut qu'ils
fassent clairement leur travail et que
quand ben c'est comme les policiers
c'est comme tout citoyen quand quand ils
ne respectent pas quand il tape sur des
gens alors qu'ils n'ont pas à le faire
eh bien il faut qu'il soit sanctionné
ils ont pas être au-dessus de la loi en
fait un dernier mot concernant l'article
24 est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous demander
le retrait tout simplement de cet
article ou l'ensemble de cette loi à
l'ensemble de cette loi parce que là on
parle beaucoup de l'article 24 parce
qu'il parle mais je
il ya aussi les articles qui parlent ou
maintenant dans les manifestations on va
mettre des drones avec de la
reconnaissance faciale
c'est quand même juste on n'en parle pas
beaucoup mais c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent donné pendant ce temps là on
n'augmente pas les soignants qui sont
premiers feront sur le kobe 19 on trouve
pas l'argent sur ça on démantèle aux
services publics
donc en fait un moment donné c'est
l'ensemble de cette loi comme le demande
de plusieurs ong qu'il faut qu'il faut
retirer parce que ce n'est pas digne de
l'histoire de de la france d'avoir cette
loi qui est con fermement liberticide et
qui attaquent nos droits merci beaucoup
emilie marsh d'avoir réagi sur rtl
france je rappelle que vous êtes
conseillère régionale la france
insoumise auvergne rhône-alpes